[Musica]
Basta con quel
[Applauso]
cellulare io sono mercoledì Adams la
vostra maestra per
oggi
mercoledì Adams è la nostra maestra per
oggi fa paura ma noi abbiamo il mio
nuovo libro La città stregata a
proteggerci è ora disponibile per il
preordine i primi che lo preordino
riceveranno in regalo il poster
autografato con l'alfabeto segreto
quindi preordino subito cliccate nel
link in descrizione ma ora stiamo
attenti alla lezione perché noi siamo i
secchioni Io sono Anita e io sono Frank
e ho un po' di paura della maestra io
sono William il popolare della scuola
Anzi mi correggo Il più popolare
mercoledì come nuova insegnante sì mi
interessa ma poco sinceramente ho altro
a cui pensare tipo tutti i miei follower
un nuovo bersaglio per i bulli Gigo eh B
sì non vedo l'ora sarà una vittima
facile
Sì silenzio e iniziamo subito con la
prima lezione questa prima lezione sarà
sulle creature più spav dose di
Halloween che spero vi torturer anno
stanotte Ah a questa lezione dovrò stare
attentissimo perché così ad Halloween
potrò crearmi da solo l'abito più
spaventoso di tutti ed essere ovviamente
il più seguito su tutti i social Sì
mostruosi Mai quanto quelli che hanno
meno di 20.000 follower ehii hai portato
quello che ti ho detto ieri Ovvio Oh sì
così possiamo fare il primo scherzo a
questa maestra che si crede chissà chi
ma vai vai vai giù giù cosa
naturale dobbiamo stare super attenti a
come riconoscere le creature spaventose
Sì hai ragione Quello lì mi sembra un
lupo mentre quello non so proprio cos'è
credo che sia un ragno Ma a proposito di
lupo mannaro Ce n'è anche uno qua nella
copertina e infatti nella nuova storia
nel nuovo mistero da risolvere La città
stregata c'è una trasformazione di un
lupo mannaro c'è un lupo mannaro anche
qua è perfetto per Halloween pre
ordinatelo subito chiosa interrompere la
mia lezione con le sue inutili e
insignificanti
parole cosa state facendo con questo
quello è il mio libro mi
[Musica]
serve paura
misteri personaggi spaventosi Io adoro
le cose spaventose
questo libro adesso è
mio Cè ancora tuo sì
Nascondilo pauroso questo Questo libro è
pieno di
misteri pensi quello che penso io e cioè
che questa è l'occasione giusta esatto
vado quello vai vai
vai
[Musica]
Guarda guarda si spaventerà tantissimo
se la farà addosso
sì
entusiasmante ma adesso ricominciamo la
lezione sulle creature
[Musica]
spaventose Ma è
bellissima Vieni qua cucciolina quanto
sei bellina
tarantolo nuovo gattino
domestico Ma come non Sii spaventata
animale
domestico il nostro Lagno ma non ha
funzionato il nostro scherzo Chi è stato
a mettere questa tarantola pelosa nella
lavagna lui lui no lui
lu è stato lui guardi maestra guardi
Guardi Ma chiunque sia stato Grazie È
sempre stato il mio sogno fin da piccola
ho sempre voluto una tarantola Eh sì io
io no no io io io fatto Beh allora
Grazie per questo regalo siete già i
miei preferiti della classe amici
follower Guardate cosa è successo alla
lezione della maestra mercoledì che
schifo quel ragno gigante sembra
velenoso e quindi pericoloso
[Musica]
aiuto che schifo Io sono la cnof
robica cia sono l'emoji di Anita Sbaglio
o ancora non hai cliccato mi piace Mi
raccomando Clicca subito mi piace sotto
a questo video e se non hai ancora il
mio nuovo libro La città stregata agli
investigatori del mistero Clicca nel
link in descrizione Per ordinarlo subito
e lo troverai in libreria dal 17 ottobre
Prendilo anche tu per entrare a far
parte del nostro team di investigatori e
risolveremo un sacco di misteri assieme
Wow i selfie col mio nuovo iPhone 37,5
super Gig
xyw escono veramente benissimo me l'ha
comprato nuovo nuovo il mio papi
ovviamente noi ce lo possiamo permettere
Non come voi secchioni che siete ancora
Fermi all'iPhone 2 è talmente nuovo che
non gli ho tolto ancora neanche la
pellicola Ma guarda questo viziato che
con quel
telefono Che emozione è talmente
antipatico che io un giorno a quell'
ione con super mega ultra e tutti gli
ambaradan glielo rubo glielo ridò e poi
glielo Gli rubo
benissimo così ci rimane male due polve
adesso seconda
lezione pozioni adesso create la vostra
pozione con gli ingredienti che avete a
disposizione sul banco ma state attenti
perché tra gli ingredienti c'è un veleno
mortale e chi ha studiato sa
riconoscerlo Mentre chi non ha studiato
Beh Peggio per
lui ma io non ho studiato Tu hai
studiato Secondo te No ma infatti noi
non studiamo mai dobbiamo andare a casa
per forza Oh ti troverò Scegli con
attenzione Oh sei tu allora io prendo
questa Vai cincin all salute speriamo
Spero non sia quella mortale nel caso la
do a bere a Frankie no tocca a me questo
non ha un bruttissimo colore Spero che
non sia il veleno mortale Guarda che
colore strano
Oh ma puzza di di ascella di maestra
Santina Che schifo fa proprio schifo Ma
che schifo di colori sono quelli
veramente non vi dico cosa sembrano si
vede proprio che siete due poveracci non
come me il mio colore sarà bellissimo Si
abbinerà tutto il mio guardaroba e poi
io questa ampolla super mega 3000 XY XL
non come le vostre dunque Oh la mia
diretta quotidiana come faccio a
dimenticarmene ragazzi Vi rendete conto
con questa sfida rischio di morire cioè
io tipo # scioccato Chissà che colore
verrà
[Musica]
fuori No vabbè è lo stesso colore della
Chevrolet del papi sarà fierissimo di me
questa sfida è facilissima per noi
secchioni perché noi abbiamo studiato e
infatti Sappiamo benissimo che quella
mortale è questa Mera vero
Sì quindi prendiamo un altro colore
giusto Ehi ma che fai è quella mortale
quello Ma tu sei secchione dovresti aver
studiato Esatto ma son così intelligente
che ho capito che mischiando boccetta
verde con boccetta blu si ottiene una
cosa benefica e non la morte meglio non
rischiare Ok Tieni Usa questa
bella Wow che bel colore la mia pozione
bella è la mia più
intelligente Guardate che pozione
meravigliosa che ho creato non di certo
come quella della secchiona Anita
Guardate che schifo di colore Ehi ma
come ti permetti la mia pozione è
perfetta Anche perché io ho studiato
chissà cosa c'è nella tua di pozione beh
Cosa c'è Non mi interessa So solo che è
un bellissimo colore e si abbina con
tutta la mia palette di colori
dell' William Basta con quel
cellulare dammi quel No la prego qua
dentro c'è tutta la mia vita dammelo
brutto
[Musica]
scorio facciamo fare al tuo nuovo iPhone
un bel bagnetto così
[Musica]
[Applauso]
impare
[Musica]
[Applauso]
ah
come farò adesso tutti i miei follower
Mi sentite
follower be il vero un po' gli sta bene
al Popolare era troppo
antipatico il bambino viziato ha preso
quello che
meritava Adesso ho un iPhone
pluff Troppo divertente questa lezione
bene adesso Passiamo alla terza e ultima
lezione che si terrà all'aperto in
questa terza lezione Vi insegnerò a
trovare il posto giusto dove scavare una
fossa per dormire ovviamente m vediamo
chi chiamare per scavare Beh tu Billy
vieni vi subito qua visto che hai
disturbato tutta la lezione forza scava
Ma perché proprio io devo scavare non
lamentarti non so se ci riesco e va bene
Ci provo
Ah forza dei bulli a
me Oh ma sono
fortissimo G
almeno non ha chiamato a me ma chi se ne
frega a me non interessa solo del mio
telefono non so più cosa fare senza Ehi
Anita
Ehi voi che cosa state scog ditando
Adesso vi seppellirò nella Bucca che sta
facendo Billy Ehi voi ma perché non ci
alleiamo tutti e tre insieme così la
facciamo pagare ai Bulli e alla maestra
che mi ha buttato il telefono nell'acqua
Sì esatto Mi sembra che tra loro ci sia
un grande legame Sì è vero dobbiamo
riuscire a difenderci da loro restiamo
uniti contro i bulli e contro
mercoledì Complimenti Billy stai andando
molto bene grazie maestra e comunque le
volevo dire maestra è un'ottima idea
quella di seppellire i secchioni e il
popolare io bullo E sì sì son qui noi
l'aiuteranno sì sì sì grazie mille siamo
pronti siamo pronti Oh sì siamo pronti
avete sentito vogliono sepre allerg
nella fossa dobbiamo fare qualcosa Ho
un'idea il
libro
Guardate Ehi ma dove sono cosa mi è
successo Ehi
cosa mi avete fatto con i poteri del
libro l'abbiamo
rimpicciolita Come vi siete permessi a
fare questa perc di Y e la farò pagare
cosa gli hanno fatto qua le cose si
mettono molto male dobiamo SC scappiamo
scappiamo Così impari a terrorizzare i
secchioni e a buttarmi il telefono
nell'acqua Esatto io non ci vedo Mettiti
gli
occhiali forse voi non sapete che occhi
avete che fare benenti sta
mercoledì ora rimani minuscola non
potrai più terrorizzare nessuno al
massimo le
formiche Ciao ciao
mercoledì
Addio bene la nostra avventura si
conclude qua e io vi ricordo che potete
già preordinare il libro La città
stregata cliccate nel link in
descrizione e alla prossima Ciao